artur quería investigar cómo le afectaba
su peso la cantidad de ejercicio que
hace cada día de la semana pasada
registró su peso y el número de horas
que hizo ejercicio un número positivo
significa que subió de peso un número
negativo significa que perdió peso supón
que artur quiere crear un diagrama de
dispersión de acuerdo a los datos que se
presentan debajo completa los siguientes
enunciados
la cantidad de ejercicio debería ir en
el eje normalmente nuestra variable
independiente en nuestra variable
principal va a ir en el eje de las x el
ejercicio es nuestra variable principal
ya que la pérdida o ganancia de peso
depende del ejercicio que se hace
entonces la cantidad de ejercicio
debería ir en el eje horizontal el rango
del eje debería ir desde hasta bueno
vemos que el rango de números tenemos
para las horas de ejercicio 30 38 vemos
que los números van del 0,3 hasta 8 no
de hecho hasta 89 horas de ejercicio es
bastante ejercicio entonces el rango va
de 0 a 8 como el 9 desde menos 2 no no
tenemos horas negativas así que tiene
que ser cero hasta 2 no nos sirve
tendría que ser 10 para que entre este
veamos nuestra respuesta encontramos la
respuesta correcta